hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and it's friday what is this september
2nd 2020 and you know today was non-farm
payrolls and wow it was a very roller
coaster day you know the the number came
out the market rallied
sold off a little bit after the cash
open rallied again to new highs and then
sold off but once it hit a certain level
i think it was 39 uh 98 it just it was
all over i didn't think the market was
going to come back
and you know just really quick if you
remember yesterday september 1st right
we had that big rally up late in the day
and we had the lows uh yesterday
just around 10
in the morning just after 10 and then
you know had a high of around 30 9 30.
but just around 12 o'clock we hit the
3906 level and then we just rallied the
rest of the day made new highs
going into the close and that was a big
move you know you're talking from 06 all
the way up into the 70s and i remember
this morning early this morning you know
people are saying oh you know these
banks everyone they had the inside scoop
on the number you know they're all
buying in here at 20. and you know look
at what happened today right we rallied
up then we sold off sold off sold off
sold off came down towards yesterday's
low and there were some interesting
things up here in the order flow around
this uh 39
98 and 39 88 and a quarter level and
let's take a look at the order flow
um so this was the cash open right so we
were rallying you know obviously we had
a number at 7 30 this morning chicago
time rallied up and around 825 we hit a
high new high
and cash just opened and selling came in
right we had a nice sell-off of about 30
points uh we got down to what was it i
think
around in here 70 something
you know we put in this low sort of went
sideways then we rallied right back up
and started making these uh new highs
right up in here
and then just sort of went sideways it
looked like we're going to break but
once we got you know just we spent a lot
of time going sideways it's around 11
o'clock that the sell-off started
happening you know we're up here near
the highs of the day and you you're
seeing
there's little pockets of buying but
then they're selling also coming in
right the deltas even though you have
some buying you know 300 160 299 204 437
you would still get the selling would
come in right after that you know
negative delta 1 83 118 130 154
some smallish delta in here
and then it just just seems like more
selling than buying in terms of delta
and then the market just started coming
off around 11 o'clock okay and they were
trading still above 4 000 at that point
but this is where it got really
interesting this 39 80
39 98 level big bids in here you see the
volume that traded on the footprint when
we expand this
30 to 35 right above it was uh 9.78
and then what happened once this level
broke you see um
you know
the market just dropped right we just
quickly dropped about a quick 10 points
but
what was interesting was that volume 32
35. you know if you see the volume on a
lot of these bars preceding it just this
price level the volume on that bid
is more than a lot of the volumes on
these bars you know this one was 2 900
200 1600 you know 3 900 2400 here you
got 3200 we do have a couple bars here
this was four and a half thousand this
is three and a half thousand that's
strong volume just at that level and you
know anytime i see strong volume at one
level and i mean this is like
off the richter scale volume in terms of
you know how the e-minis have been
trading recently
and you know granted it's non-farm
payroll day so you're going to get a lot
more volatility that's why you see a lot
of these bars are are quite big you know
in terms of size you know the distance
it covers to transact right because
that's really what volatility is it's
price
looking for volume it's price moving
trying to find areas where there's
there's liquidity and when you have
lack of liquidity that creates
volatility but it came in here right
that's why you see this bar is very
small right you don't have that
volatility because there's that volume
there people are transacting you got
someone a big bidder in here right
between uh 98 98 and a quarter just on
the bid side there's 4 000 contracts
so what i was watching for is
if we break this level what's going to
happen afterwards and what happens
afterwards boom stack's selling and
balance now this is probably you know a
big seller came in you know there's
probably if you were to look at the
replay of how it traded you know it's
hitting it it's hitting it it's hitting
it then someone just came in and whacked
it all
probably triggered some stops because a
lot of people see this as a level right
we haven't been trading 39.88
for quite some time all right just draw
this line and go back
see what time the last time we were
trading this uh 98 level was
back here at 9 23
okay so
you know we 98 we got all the way up
into the teens you know above 4 000 and
we're coming back down in here
everyone sees this level everyone you
know is looking at book map you know
these heat maps they can see there's a
big
big buyer in here but if that level
breaks
which it did
and you see that aggressive selling you
know and people talk about um you know
in market profile there's initiative
buying initiative selling responsive
buying
you know responsive selling
we're starting to break down now you're
seeing this what's initiative selling
you know people coming in they're
selling below value in anticipation of
lower prices and again this bar broke it
broke from you know 88 and a quarter or
88 in a quarter down all the way down to
i say that's 98 and a quarter down to 88
and a quarter it's a 10 point drop
immediately and it hits this 88 and a
quarter and there's another big bid
sitting there in the market okay first
time it trades 86 contracts then the
markets just go inside on you for one
two three four
five bars
six bars seven bars but you can see the
volumes
14 58 24 there's there's a big bid in
here again
you know it's close to you know this is
um three thousand
four thousand
right 24 439 that's about four or three
thousand four and a half thousand even
above it you're seeing big bonds because
everyone sees this big bit everyone's
trying to step in front of this bid
and buy it
right
now we're going to bounce what was
interesting it's about 10 points you
know from
eight even down 98 even down to you know
88 and a quarter
got another big bitter in here and the
mark is it's kind of holding
right you can see it held this level
once it really started pounding into it
one minute two minutes three minutes
four minutes was there any really rally
not really about uh two point rally this
time it just earlier just blew right
through that level
and then finally broke that level now
you don't see that initiative selling in
here i mean sure they're selling people
are hitting these bids
but what was interesting is you don't
have that stacked imbalance the way that
you had it right here
okay and this market sold off it sold
off down to 85 and a quarter and it
rallied right back up to you know back
up to that level 88 and a quarter 89
actually closed up right had a small
delta
of minus 142. normally this this bar is
the type of bar i like to get long on
right it had that big negative delta
and it closed up it had a small negative
delta so it gained a lot of it back
looked like it was going to start to
rally
but it didn't right it went up three
price levels you know that's enough for
me to get excited honestly i thought
this market was going to start rallying
off this but again what we had big size
up here now we got big size down here
we're trading below it if you have a big
size that's you're looking to be support
of the market you shouldn't be trading
below it once you start taking out these
support levels
what's left to support the market
nothing right so you know this is even
though this is normally bullish for me
it's coming in
below a support level right now
trading 101 is you buy support you sell
resistance but when you break support or
you break resistance and you spend more
time below it necessarily than above it
it's probably not going to hold anymore
right support resistance doesn't hold
forever it's just like you know hold the
line hold the line
all right us ape stronger together well
once the line gets broken
it's weak right you can't be thinking
this as support now you guys start
looking for
potential shorts because one you got
some nice bullish information in the
market it's not rallying off this so
forget about it being support at this
point right you broke support here you
broke support here now we're just sort
of hovering around the support we're
nowhere near back up this 88 sorry this
98 level so
you know kiss this 98 level goodbye for
the day now we're starting to see
bearish stuff coming in the order flow
nice strong negative delta 400
followed by 1100 now we're seeing that
initiative selling coming in here the
stack selling and balance and it's just
look out below right and then the market
sells off
quite nicely right and almost
methodically all the way down again
there's even though you know you see
these little bounces
it's not buying opportunities right
there's nothing really presenting itself
in the order flows screaming out hey buy
me
right we're markets cheap buy it now
right even though it's non-farm payrolls
and you know historically
non-farm payrolls closes up on the day
now we're coming under a lot of selling
pressure flow driven market
divergence
you know here's a bullish ratio and
we're just going sideways why isn't this
market rallying right you're starting to
see signs of aggressive buying coming in
here but the market can't rally it's not
rallying off that you know all you're
seeing really is just sort of profit
taking
and identifying that
what kind of a market that we're in
right now again we're just trading 39
39.98 basically 4 000
and an hour and a half later we're
trading you know that down in the 39 30s
right you're starting to see more
divergences divergence divergence what
is a divergence well it's a new or equal
low with positive delta in this case
these are bullish divergences and we're
just taking them out with impunity right
they don't
it's not standing in the way what's
happening is
obviously in a flow driven market i mean
it's one thing to say oh yeah we're
making these new lows
you know we're in a flow driven market
after we just sold off 70 points i mean
that should be obvious already
but again one of my favorite trades is
watching when you get in these
failed divergences
understanding we're in a flow driven
market
and the great shorting opportunities
okay
and you're going to be looking and
you've got one two three four
within you know this is from 12 27 to 12
30 so within 10 minutes
so it's quite strong
right this one the market did bounce up
off of
but again you just got to be ready to
short those right because
in a flow driven market
you really got the other time frame
traders right the big money the guys
with the deep pockets
that are driving this market they don't
care about support at this level it was
obvious earlier when you saw the big
size right when you saw the three and a
half thousand contracts the four and a
half thousand contracts and the market
just sort of got through it right got
through the three thousand three and a
half thousand contracts very easily
the four thousand and a half thousand
four and a half thousand it took a
little bit more time to get through but
it got through that so you should
already
spot the type of market that we're in
doesn't have to necessarily be making
new lows to be
saying oh we're in a flow driven market
to the downside that should have been
obvious you know 50 points higher then
you're coming down in here it's still
being flow driven right because any
little buying opportunity is failing
then it just keeps dropping right drops
all the way down to 39.25
um even later you know again it looks
like maybe you know this is it we're
going to stop that's our low for the day
which sort of hangs around hangs around
and then the selling continues right
more failed divergence right we get all
the way down literally
down
to you know the the o6 level
right and it's interesting because this
06 level yesterday
in the order flow
you know just draw this line here
um go back to yesterday when we hit that
06 level remember the yesterday the low
was like 3
three and a quarter three and a half or
something but yesterday
look at that we hit that
uh
where is it here
we came down to it right in here this is
before that big rally back up
um
just before 12 o'clock you're coming
into this area right and
you know i did this video yesterday
talking about these
side by side these aligned pointed
controls being support
next time you come down and test it
this is coming in at six and a half
right our level
that we hit today was oh six so yeah you
know we got through it by i'll just draw
the other one because this is this is
where the level started right here
six
and a half
but um so it was interesting that we
came back literally
i mean we did overshoot it by what two
ticks
here to the low of oh six but you
know we just sold off a hundred and
almost 115 points for the day not ticks
115 points
and you just overshot it by this is six
and a half so
two ticks and then
put in this big months now say big
monster rally it was a big rally from
you know the six
six and a half area probably up into the
20s right there um before you know it
hit that and then it
went higher um close the day but you
know when you see it come up in here
going into the close again you know
getting out in the 20s would have been a
good area but still you know just one of
those coincidence things um
that it that it happened it's you know i
don't like to pull those levels from the
day before but i just i just thought it
was interesting because yesterday i
posted that video about the point of
controls um you know when you get two in
a row acting as important resistance and
then what happens today we literally hit
that level by
you know you just get past it by two
ticks but again we had this monster
sell-off from the high of the day down
to the low of the day um
so i'm not surprised to see it take it
out by a couple of ticks
you know then the market rallied but you
know what was interesting on here is you
had the stack selling and balance here
in this green bar um that's why we draw
this area as blue because that's a
bullish sign
and the market did pop back up off that
again that was going into the close but
you know if you made it to this time at
uh
2 50 in the afternoon if you've been
training all day you know hats off to
you congratulations you probably just
felt like you've been in uh
trading not trading water but like
swimming in the ocean and in the heavy
waves all day long because it was uh
it was pretty
nasty day but you know it's very active
you know uh honestly robust trading day
a lot of opportunities so i hope you
guys uh found this video useful you know
it's funny because you know i'll get
comments from people saying oh you know
2020 is hindsight well yeah you know the
reason i make these videos is
to show you guys things that what to
look for so next time it happens
you know hopefully it'll register in
your head oh yeah you know what mike
explained this to me before it's not
like
you know
that's why you know football players
review tapes right that's why baseball
players review tapes of how pitchers
pitch all that sort of information
is
is useful to us as traders right it's
not just about sitting there and
you all can only watch the market in
real time no you still got to go back
and and look at what happened and put
the pieces together so the next time it
happens
when you're in front of the screen in
real time you know how to react okay so
if you like this video be sure to
subscribe to the channel hit the like
button put some comments below
positive comments keep it positive guys
i mean that's the whole reason for doing
things like this you know everyone wants
to improve the trading
so thanks everyone have a great day bye